do-do-do-do down we're done I think you
turned it off I am obviously pretty good
at it you know I've been uh been
practicing a lot oh yeah I'm ready to
rock okay I predict we actually won't be
worse ones at this right I mean it
really can't go much what are you doing
[Music]
did you not hear the part where I said
no one taught me how to sell okay but
you know how buttons work right ironing
is pretty basic
except for pleats so now can't be afraid
I think your tutu skirt all right it's
gonna be I know you're scared but this
skirt will be okay in the end you took
out all the pleats
you're new in a pretty good job check
this out by the way I don't yeah she
doesn't know how to sort at all drew Oh
have you met before what is this device
no we get one of these let's say you
just put that just you just throw that
little thingy yeah yeah look at that and
then BOOM
that was it boom you gotta put the
clothes oh okay
they're stupid pleats we might not have
anything to fight about AFE yeah yeah
like ever again ah I feel like this one
was who's easier than the others right
yeah